With extending the light switch now completed,
that is gonna go ahead and wrap up
this video tutorial series.
Now we first started this video tutorial series
talking about object oriented concepts.
Remember this deals with the parent child relationship
where parents establish default functionality
that's then passed down to the children
and the children can override or extend
that default functionality
that they receive from the parents.
We then took a look at the difference
between the controller and pawn classes
and why we wanna have one single controller
control multiple pawns.
We then moved on to working with blueprint interfaces
and why these are important, not only for optimization,
but also makes it very easy
to have blueprints interact with one another.
We then took all of this information that we discussed
and put it to use by creating a light switch
that when activated can turn off a specific light
and we follow that up with extending that light switch
to allow us to select multiple lights
so the same light switch would turn multiple lights off
instead of just a single one.
I hope you enjoyed this video tutorial series.
My name is Sam Deiter with Epic Games
and I'll see you next time.